here he is jesus lozado 23 year old he
was born in peru but as you know he grew
up right here in south florida stoneman
douglas he's trying to get on track
we've seen some glimpses though and he
gets behind in the count then he throws
the ball in the middle
jonathan india hits that one middle high
in the air deep left field staggered
strides to the wall off the wall alfaro
couldn't find it india claims second and
the reds have their lead off man in
scoring position
he has phenomenal stuff he has stuff to
be a very dominant pitcher in this
league
how many left-handers you go around how
many left-handers throw 97-98 and can
throw a long time in the ball game he
leaves that ball in the middle of the
plate and that is a common occurrence
for this young left-hander
and he goes to the changeup to get
castellanos that's out number one
but still one of the
greatest hitters in franchise history
and he is called out on strikes
lozardo goes away with a fastball at 97
miles an hour
certainly looks like it's a little bit
outside that strike zone
maybe more than a little bit but he
definitely gets the call he's awaits a
2-0 pitch and grounds it back to luzardo
makes the play
and flips to first nice job able to work
around the double and the walk tyler
malley has the ball for the reds his
numbers from western and southern where
would the reds be without the start of
tyler malley and you look back early in
the season he was the reds best pitcher
i mean he came out of the gate
gangbusters 1-1 there's a sharp ground
ball deep short diving stop farmer to
his feet throws got him wow
how about that play from kyle farmer
deep in the hole a diving stop falling
to his feet he made the throw
and gets the out of rojas
chisholm drives one into the right
center field gap and castellanos makes
the running catch
what a play by nick castiano's running
into the alley on that line drive off
the bat of jazz chisholm
there's a base hit
[Applause]
knock up the middle for aguilar there he
goes 3-2 coming and sanchez down the
line if it stays fair it's long gone and
it's long gone
hey zu sanchez with a two-run shot in
the first inning and the marlins
[Music]
he got himself back to the full count he
was sitting on a fast ball gets it at
the knees
[Applause]
now tyler naquin
tyler naquin bounces one deep in the
hole at second off the glove of chisholm
bending down to pick it up way over in
the hole and naquin is aboard we'll see
if that'll be scored ahead if it is it
extends the hit streak to 18 games for
tyler naquin
and he goes to the change up gets malley
and strands a runner
good inning for lucardo
two-nothing marlons you go to the bottom
of the second inning
high heat swing and a miss first
strikeout for tyler malley
strike three cold a couple of k's for
maui book end is load walking
needed 40 to get through two scoreless
frames the next pitch is crack to left
field alfaro got turned around now he
runs back and over his right shoulder
makes the catch
he took a step in he took a step to his
left then realized he's got to go back
to his right and alfaro retreated down
to the warning track
3-2 pitch swing in the mid strike three
when chasing for a curveball and he came
up empty no runs no hits nobody left
that base he's got 20 straight road
starts allowing three or fewer runs that
is the longest active streak
in baseball going back to 2019.
beautiful pitch on the edge and rojas
goes down looking you watch this pitch
it starts over by the shin guard of
tyler stevenson well off the plate but
the ball begins to come back does he get
all the way back to the plate probably
not and jesus rosardo had himself one
heck of an inning he's he's locked in
right now
and bono chases
a breaking ball he's gotten him twice
and that's 5ks for luzardo 3-2 pitch to
suarez
and it's the curveball for lucardo he's
got six strikeouts tying the most that
he's had in his start
as a marlin six home runs now for jesus
sanchez
goes down looking as malley paints three
straight fastballs in on sanchez
right back to it can't catch it i mean
that's three straight fastballs
and he gets that buy-in three strikeouts
in the inning for mali six on his dick
back to work here
called out on strikes he didn't like the
call
mali lines it
out to right field in a one two three
inning
for jesus luzardo who has been locked in
jarrow walked in the second inning
sierra
pulls that bunt to first and is able to
beat it out
sierra on for the second time i love
this
directional bunting
[Applause]
with this but the entire time and once
he gets past mali
there's no chance that malley was going
to get it on the ground
now lizardo bunts
overhand flip to india covering sierra
the third fire down it's there out of
third base double play nicely done
india extends and takes away this is one
of those innings that can reinvigorate
your offense awfully good that's an
emotional lift for the ribs
11 in a row retired by luzardo
that is a strikeout for luzardo his
eighth to match a season and career
is working on a one hit shutout that
hits
there's a base runner this could very
well
help the reds
now what a day for jesus losarto his
best start as a marlin
he was spectacular today tying a
career-high with eight strikeouts
payoff pitch from bender
is a call strike three
suarez doesn't like
the call and he gets thrown out
now david bell is out both sides but
maybe more so the reds today have had a
little bit of an issue with the strike
zone that looked like it clipped the top
i could see suarez's case we talked so
much about this strike zone but i will
say and it's not you know my favorite
way to go about this but he's been
consistent we've seen the marlins
complaining about it we've seen the reds
complaining about it dylan floro is on
the pitch his 54th
game of the year will face the top of
the reds order jonathan india to leap
things off
ground ball anderson
no play
infield hit tyler stevenson
ground ball
he'll move the man up tagged out
by aguilar
tying runs in scoring position with one
out
motto
center field
sierra makes the catch tag at third
india he scores on a sac fly reds on the
board 2-1
wow that's a tough pitch that's a really
good pitch by dylan
floro and now david bell is coming out
he's going to end up getting thrown out
of the ball game
and bell has been tossed
hey eugenio suarez was ejected joey
votto's been
vehemently upset a couple of times david
bell
he loves his players he has their back
florro delivers
swing and a miss strike three
it's a marlins win
the marlins take two out of three from
the cincinnati reds
just a couple of hits today
and the marlins end up going four and
two on the home stand
and quiet down these red hot reds bats
and the greatest start of luzado's
marlins career